bonjour alain scène ira merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct ce matin dans
la matinale berthet france situation
préoccupante en afrique du sud expliquez
nous pourquoi
pour le moment pas de problème ya
quelques cas de variants indien mais la
situation n'est pas encore inquiétante
n'y a que quelques cas 3 4 cas de percée
des indiens qui ont débarqué qui était
positif avec ce variant mais on nous a
dit qu'il ne faut pas qu'on panique et
une communauté indienne sur plots il ya
une communauté indienne également à
assez assez fortes ont effectivement
c'est un bateau qui transportait du riz
de l'aide et il y aurait de quelques
personnes j'ai des partis qui étaient
positives avec ce pas comment est ce que
l'afrique du sud fait face à la crise
sanitaire y at il encore des
restrictions et est ce que la campagne
de vaccination est satisfaisante
il ya très peu de restrictions pour le
moment nous attend nous attendons la
troisième vague lacan indirects comme la
bd était interrompue avec la astrazeneca
le johnson & johnson a été interrompue
momentanément et quant à une vaccination
va reprendre la semaine prochaine
alors est-ce qu'elle a suffisamment de
vaccins l'afrique du sud pour vacciner
sa population
non pas du tout nous sommes sans retard
même par rapport aux pays d'afrique
zimbabwe le reste de l'afrique
la cause de cette interruption à cause
des interruptions
oui à cause du mariage si l'africain qui
ne résiste en alaska zenica et puis le
johnson & johnson comme ou là mais on
savait y avait des ddd réaction de
coagulation google on avait été
interrompu et le comment d'arrêter mais
bon tout a été repris on espère
commencer à saint projet est-ce que là
elle influence
[Musique]
le personnel médical jusqu'à présent est
ce que l'afrique du sud bénéficie du
programme kovacs je pense que oui je
pense que oui vous savez l'afrique du
sud produisent et ses propres vaccins
jusqu'en 2001 et ça a été interrompue
parce que le coup était trop chez
c'était moins celle importée des vaccins
donc il ya ils vont probablement
recommencer à fabriquer le vaccin
l'afrique du sud mais ça prend du temps
le la levée des brevets a été actée par
le président américain c'est une bonne
nouvelle
oui c'est une très bonne nouvelle je ne
sais pas c'est effectivement nous allons
voir nathan dans le vaccin fond sur le
point d'arriver et d'être acceptée par
le conseil médical pharmaceutique les
ils vont relancer la campagne de
vaccination la semaine prochaine la
laissera sûrement oui c'est pas beaucoup
à la saison hivernale approche est ce
que ça aussi ça peut compliquer les
choses ça le problème
nous sommes où la troisième vague et sur
ma famille à tous crins c'est une
augmentation du nombre de cas même c'est
pas simplement qu'en est il des
campagnes de dépistage
est-ce que c'est satisfaisant pas
vraiment je pense que même un petit pot
sa population quasi dépister ce qu'il
très bas mais on dit viens pour sa
population ont été immunisés
naturellement le nombre de cas
d'hospitalisation dans les hôpitaux
publics en toc toc river est très bas
donc il ya pas de saturation dans l'est
dans les hôpitaux on parle de d'une
certaine corruption également dans l'est
les attestations justement de pcr de
personnes qui seraient positives et qui
essaierait d'obtenir des des
attestations à négative est ce que c'est
le cas
écoutez je n'aime pas vos contenus
palais ça je sais que ça se passait
partout dans le monde mais actuellement
franchement je vous dire vraiment donc
là vous êtes plutôt optimiste pourrait
pour la suite pour les vagues pour la
vaccination
oui je pense que la campagne a lancé
tout organisé tout est mis en place
nous avons à l'époque simplement merci
merci beaucoup à l'insa nuad avoir fait
un point pour nous en direct dans la
matinale de rtl france / sur l'afrique
du sud ce matin en direct de
johannesburg